Rey has been using hammy downs since the
first moment she touched a lightsaber in
the force awakens but with the ending of
the rise of Skywalker she finally has
one of her own here's what Ray's new
lightsaber really means in the force
awakens Rey first wielded Luke
Skywalker's old lightsaber which
originally belonged to Anakin Skywalker
with Emperor Palpatine finally defeated
Rey returns to where fans journey with
star wars began 42 years ago the
Lawrence family moisture farm on the
planet Tatooine were Luke grew up Rey
berries both Luke's famous lightsaber
and the one Leia used when she was
training to become a Jedi in the desert
near the farm before pulling out a new
lightsaber she is finally forged for
herself
fortunately for fans it's not the double
bladed red lightsaber seen in the
trailers for the rise of Skywalker the
lightsaber that Rey ends up with is a
yellow lightsaber which is quite rare in
the Star Wars universe
the yellow lightsaber has most often
been seen in the galaxy far far away in
the hands of the temple guards on the
animated series Star Wars the Clone Wars
of course Rey is certainly not joining
the temple guard considering the Jedi
Temple would be fairly empty given the
lack of Jedi but there's plenty of other
symbolism attached to the yellow
lightsaber as well Star Wars lore
dictates that yellow lightsabers are
carried by the sentinels one of the
major schools of thought within the old
Jedi Order that tries to find balance
between the consulars which typically
bear green blades and the guardians who
normally wield blue lightsabers with the
Sith apparently destroyed by the end of
the rise of Skywalker Rey has finally
brought balance to the force not only
that but she also appears to be the only
Jedi left and will have to carry the
beliefs of them all into the future
there's also the symbolic decision for
raid to deviate from what has come
before her Reyes had quite the journey
she was a poor scavenger girl abandoned
on jakku by her parents who spent most
of her life waiting for them to come
back to her then discovered that she's
force sensitive began training as a Jedi
under Luke Skywalker joined the
resistance and fought against the first
order found out she's a Palpatine and
ultimately decided to take the surname
Skywalker as her own she had plenty of
options from which to choose
in claiming her own lightsaber she could
have been blue or green like Luke and
Leia or red like her cackling electric
grandpa
but in choosing to go a different way
with her lightsaber Rey chooses her own
identity separate from her bloodline in
her past that is scavenging as the only
way to survive in the desert wasteland
she knows firsthand how important
knowledge outside the forest can be to
survival that's just what the Sentinels
believe all things considered it makes
perfect sense that she would choose to
follow the school of thought embodied by
the Sentinels and forging her own
lightsaber additionally it was important
for Rey to put Luke and Leia's
lightsabers to rest and forge one of her
own it's critical part of the process to
becoming a Jedi Master and until she did
so would have rendered her journey
incomplete Star Wars lore also dictates
that the Kyber crystals used create the
light and a lightsaber or white and only
take on a color once they have bonded
with a Jedi and their path becomes clear
the message here is an obvious one Rey
the last of the Jedi Order will embody
all that the Jedi are from the consulars
to the guardians to learning real-life
skills
Rey carries the entire future of the
Jedi Order within her and she must
balance those teachings there's another
small detail to Ray's new lightsaber
many may have missed the handle of her
saber is made from the staff she has
been carrying around for years since
long before she ever left jakku in the
first place it's yet another piece of
symbolism showing rey finally leaving
her old life behind her this time for
good
even in the rise of skywalker we saw
that Rey's education is the chat I
hadn't given her the confidence to rely
on her strength in the forest just yet
on the training ground she was unable to
fight off the combat remote the
lightsaber but she disposed of it
quickly using a stick like her staff she
has always been comfortable with the
weapon in her hand so it makes perfect
sense for her to bring that relic
forward with her into her new life
without hanging on to any sentimentality
of her past it's understood that the new
Star Wars films won't be telling the
tale of the Skywalker's of which Rey is
now won by choice thanks to her final
words and the rise of Skywalker
considering the rise of Skywalker marked
the end of the Skywalker saga it's not
likely Rey will be returning in any more
this ties in with one of the reasons the
Sentinels don't appear in the nine films
already in existence
those who practice the beliefs of the
Sentinels believed in concealing
themselves and becoming inconspicuous
and avoided pulling out their
lightsabers unless absolutely necessary
but the galaxy seemingly safe at the end
of the rise of Skywalker Ray's shouldn't
need to whip out her new weapon that
often and may even be able to fade into
the background just like the Sentinels
but who knows maybe she'll teach a whole
new order of Jedi in the future and
we'll meet her students in a future Star
Wars movie check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite Star Wars
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]